[Musica]
le volte del futuro
che cosa significa volta
è un termine che possiamo interpretare
come voltarsi ma voltarsi verso cosa o
per che cosa
per spiegare l'interpretazione che ho
dato a questo termine vorrei raccontarvi
il mito di orfeo
orfeo era un poeta che perse la sua ma
teorie dice per il morso di un serpente
disperato convinse con la dolcezza della
sua musica
ade e persefone dei degli inferi a
restituirgli la sua amata dato che il
filo della sua vita era stato spezzato
precocemente
idea gli concessero questa possibilità
di recuperare l'amata a patto che nel
tragitto di ritorno sulla terra egli non
si voltasse a guardarla
ma quasi sopraggiunto all'uscita egli si
voltò e nel voltarsi perse per sempre la
sua amata
improvvisamente si ritrova in un oblio
un vuoto di disperazioni dovuto alla
perdita del suo amore per la seconda
volta e che lo portò ad abbandonare il
canto per tre anni
di sicuro vi starete chiedendo come mai
orfeo si voltò
così vicino ai avere la sua amata
e lì si voltò per assicurarsi della sua
presenza per il timore di perdere quella
donna che per lui era una costante e
quindi per ritrovare certezza e
stabilità
tutti abbiamo costanti nella nostra vita
sono come ancora ci legano e questo
attaccamento alle cose alle persone che
fanno parte del nostro passato non fanno
che frenarci
esse generano il timore di perdere
questi affetti e che spesso ci porta
alla staticità
all'inerzia e ci fa cadere nello stesso
bio di orfeo
ci legano
quindi forse ciò che può insegnarci è di
non ancorarci al passato di noi legarci
eccessivamente adesso ma di avere il
coraggio di lasciarsi andare
a scoprire come un vuoto altro non è che
creare spazio per nuove opportunità
guardarsi dietro è normale come lo è
imparare dai propri errori per evitare
di commetterli nuovamente
ma chissà se lo al figlio di oggi si
sarebbe ancora voltato
sento questo mito vicino perché mi è
capitato di sentirmi come orfeo di
perdere la mia costante
come sono sicura sia capitato a molti di
voi
ho perso di vista quelli che erano i
miei obiettivi
i miei propositi e missy voli quotidiani
mi sono sentita sola
smarrita e persa sono caduta nel mare
dell'incertezza
e nel mio momento di smarrimento la
chiave di volta che mi ha riportato a
galla è stata mia sorella
sono convinta che nei momenti di
difficoltà e di disorientamento le
persone che ci circondano la comunità
possano essere fondamentali nella
aiutarci a portarci dal passato verso il
futuro
le volte devono essere il moto del
nostro futuro
come in una danza della vita dove ogni
sguardo incontra il suo io del passato
per conoscere il noe del futuro
creato dal nostro presente
l'unico atto di cui siamo a conoscenza
che possiamo controllare che possiamo
cambiare
un passato che non si può riavvolgere
come la pellicola di un film ma un
passato dal quale importante capire cosa
trattenere cosa conservare
per poterci rivolgere al futuro
che come una forza invisibile ci
trascina inevitabilmente verso di sé
quindi insieme possiamo voltarci o
meglio proseguire la danza della vita
dove l'io diventa a noi
come in un ballo di gruppo
come nell'opera di matisse
quest'opera si intitola la danza
dove mathis ha raffigurato degli uomini
nudi che si slanciano l'uno verso
l'altro per tenere chiuso un cerchio
notiamo però un piccolo dettaglio
le mani delle due figure in primo piano
non si toccano
ma cercano di avvicinarsi l'un l'altra
al fine di dare un senso di movimento
di unione e di attenzione verso il
prossimo dato che l'uomo pro tende la
mano verso la donna
la novità simboleggia poi ritorna ad una
natura primitiva e priva di sensi di
colpa
le figure sono circondate poi da un
verde e un blu scuro a simboleggiare la
terra e il cielo ma non la nostra
atmosfera
bensì qualcosa di più ampio
qualcosa di infinito
qualcosa di futuro
possiamo intendere l'opera come
allegoria della vita umana un movimento
continuo ma sempre teso a raggiungere
un'armonia e un equilibrio
danzano su un confine di qualcosa di
definito e riconosciuto come passato ed
è ciò a cui sono rivolti i loro sguardi
ma insieme tendono all'altra sponda
quella indefinita
quella futura
danza passo dopo passo dobbiamo tendere
anche noi verso il nostro futuro
dove ogni pasto e progresso per noi
noi come comunità
noi come società
noi
esseri umani
voltarci senza avere il coraggio di
tornare a credere nel domani
rischierebbe di far sparire per sempre
il nostro futuro
dunque impariamo da orfeo e voltiamoci
insieme verso il nostro futuro
come john fitzgerald kennedy disse
cambiare è la regola che la vita e
coloro che guardano solo al passato
solo al presente
certamente perderanno il futuro
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]